I don't know if you know my friend
he's like an unknown YouTuber I flew to
this tiny town called Greenville and I
don't even know why I don't either
who invited who Tom Logan Paul
almost def Floyd Mayweather and I'm
known for giving away money because I
assume your audience is older they're
not just 12 year old kids in this video
I take you through a raw and uncensored
day with Mr Beast bring it in from him
managing an outrageous shoot that was
dope to his relationships with his
co-stars to how much it costs to The
Strain on his mind and body to editing
it what up I'm taking over and then to
what he does in his spare time after it
all at 2 30 a.m and it's not sleep
what are you doing
where are we what are we doing so
currently we're in the middle of nowhere
[Music]
we're gonna strap a jet engine to a farm
[Music]
and then we're gonna see how many buses
it can jump over
I think one of these Corners we're gonna
turn and we're just gonna see a row of
buses yeah over there
foreign
[Music]
what if the ramp just broke this is so
steep what would you do if I literally
just drove off that I would be down but
you'd be going down
sheer scale of production on these
videos is ridiculous I'm gonna go around
and count just how many cameras it takes
to shoot a Mr Beast video
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
do you ever get nervous for [ __ ] like
this
um no not really not anymore actually in
Squid game when I had to talk in front
of 400 people I got nervous I was like
oh that's that's the Army it literally
looks like an army but no for this hell
no we're just watching a car it's fun
[Music]
where's it going
okay here make sure it still works how
much would you say the soil costs uh
this right here the buses I think we
paid like 100 G's for everything I don't
know a couple hundred grand but the
whole video probably 2 million
[Music]
is dumb
these guys they're ridiculous before
busting out the jet engine car Jimmy
first wanted to see how many buses a
normal car can jump over
good luck thank you send the car down
[Music]
the normal car managed to clear a total
of four and a half passes oh my God look
at this it went right through the window
imagine with no context seeing this hey
how did that get there looks like we set
this up doesn't it yeah it's time to
wrap things up
all right that's a good one now let's
ramp things up by putting a jet engine
on it I don't know why I try and that's
the normal car the jet engine will
probably jump all of them they might
land in the woods anything on the other
side of those trees is there anywhere
else there's no shelf it goes up let's
be real is there anything I love their
confidence there's nowhere it's all
Farmland there's no science science says
it only goes to the trees that's the
trees that's science what what if it
just doesn't you have its science
let's find out what others think uh I'd
say I'd say all of them all of them all
of them it's a jet engine between the
third and fourth bus and hopefully it'll
explode six or seven buses I'm hoping it
goes at least 10 buses they're at least
five buses at least seven if everybody
said something different and now it's
time to bring out the jet engine code
obviously not just to roast hot dogs for
an Instagram picture oh you saw those
hot dogs
hot dogs yeah that's the fourth
[Music]
how long do you usually have to wait
around like this not that normally I
mean normally we're not launching a jet
engine car over buses and there's a lot
more safety precautions I'm just kind of
like I'll do it how long till we go five
minutes it's time I'm gonna get into
position I've never been so excited
all right
oh my God
once they uh give us the green light I
can't wait to go see it
I looked
what was it like crazy okay don't swear
don't sweat it
[Music]
this is a bus stop
the jet engine car jumped over eight and
a half buses
in my entire life as a filmmaker I've
never experienced anything like this
it's just I mean
[Music]
it's crazy it's just wild is that it sir
now let's go edit on it
while Jimmy and his team started editing
the video I went and explored his Studio
this is wild production value listen to
the sound
it's completely sound treated like a
proper Sound Stage like something you
would get in the Warner Brothers Lots
it's just mind-boggling that
you know this is for YouTube
literally Any filmmaker's Dream is
everything in here any anything you need
now to find out how the post-production
process works
[Music]
one two three
four five
where's he
goes okay fair enough how long does an
edit usually take usually 16 days is our
goal but it ends up taking three weeks
16.
it's 2 30 in the morning and I can't
find Jimmy
who's been editing
I'm gonna go look upstairs
what what are you doing playing board
games I'm out of here good night I can't
believe you're still going
I'm dying but boy games are way too much
fun
just another day for Mr Beast
[Music]